hey Doug Walker here doing a quick V
Walker view of a paranormal activity the
ghost I mention um it's actually
Halloween day that I'm doing this and I
just I had a few extra minutes in
between editing and getting ready to go
to Halloween party and stuff like that
so just like okay I can do is real fast
because I forgot to do a review because
I've done all the other Paranormal
Activity movie so might as well do this
one that's I'm just gonna go out on a
limb and say is probably gonna be the
last one oh I don't think this film did
very well at the box office it fails to
know of those where was like demand it
to be seen where with the first film
everyone demanded to see in this one
like every always like I don't give a
shit so but I can't talk about this film
without talking about what I thought of
the other ones uh first one I more
admire what it did then actually liked
it I like that was very minimalist and
relied on very subtle scares and what
you don't see and stuff like that was
very patient so I like that but I didn't
like the acting or even really the what
about it too but whatever second one a
watch every Halloween gets better and
better and I think is add to one of my
favorite scary movies I know kind of a
minority on that everybody loves the
first one but am a thought was
brilliantly acted I thought was
brilliant tied together with the first
one I thought the scares are phenomenal
and I love showing it to people because
people I think always like oh well it's
a sequel it can't be good more of the
same and stuff but everyone I show it to
they're like that was fucking good and
then it's like they forget about it I
don't know that's that's a film it needs
more attention in my opinion the second
one because I think that really gets
whipped out of the corner with or under
the rug with all the other sequels like
number three which is where they start
to get a little stupid and predictable
and cliched and and the people are too
dumb but but there's still some good
scares there's still some really clever
ideas for scare so I'm like ok you know
I'm still with it fourth one gets even
stupider um but again there's still some
clever scares and I'm just I'm really
hard to scare like I I can probably
count on one hand how many scary movies
I've seen like legitimately scared me
and so when I see something that really
is trying something new and
and I I get into it uh but the fourth
one is stupid
uh and but it keeps the mystery going so
it's like okay let's I'm still with it
let's see fifth one's a piece of shit
doesn't explain anything it's not scary
the effects are getting sillier uh the
acting is good I give it that but that's
about it and a lot of people didn't go
see it so finally they release this one
claiming all the answers are gonna be in
this one it's in 3d which I did not see
it in thank God uh I go in I see this
movie and but like if you're looking to
see a film titled the ghost dimension
you probably get what you're looking for
um if you're going to see a good
Paranormal Activity movie you're not
going to get what you're looking for
this this is one of those were it's
especially the end it's kind of a it's
so bad it's good um cuz it starts off
like every other Paranormal Activity
film I mean they film everything it's
like crystal fucking clear this time you
know but whatever technology is
advancing and stuff um and it without
going into spoilers yeah I need to by
the end of this but it's another family
comes across these tapes uh and there's
one or two kind of clever things Muslim
you see in the trailer with like the
where they're watching the tapes and it
looks like the tapes can somehow hear
them like the girls from the past movies
are somehow looking into the future and
connecting with these people watching it
that's very clever that's very very
clever
um but outside of that the scares how do
I put it all the ghosts like you see
them and you see them in the trailer too
they look like cartoons uh they are
unbelievably fake I mean it's it's so
funny how these films relied on so
little and now they're just going for
the boogeyman and they just look so
horrendously bad uh but here's the thing
too even if they were gonna have the CG
monsters in there uh that which are
obviously CG monsters are very fake and
stuff like that arm you couldn't leave
to get us with the sound design cuz
there there's a lot scenes where
something flies by or something goes
wrong or and takes off or something like
there something is just looking at a
person in a bed you know and they have a
clever idea where one camera has
heightened bullshit I don't know but it
can see ghosts pretty much it's kind of
silly but it's like fair enough a it's a
new idea and I kind of like that it's
kind of like you know they live or
whatever you put the glasses on so um
yeah so there you can see the ghosts on
this camera everybody's a fucking idiot
like times a million in this because
they literally have footage of this damn
ghost and the wife is like I just I
don't know I just okay I don't think
it's there I don't know yet I it's like
just show her the damn tape it's so
stupid
and even when shit is happening they
still like it takes forever for them to
get out of this damn house ah so that's
all the dumb mistakes you've seen the
scary films but wasps gain - is even
when these things are just watching over
like the people sleeping and stuff like
that ah they have these the movie sound
effects the traditional scary movie
sound effects I mean just all these dumb
sounds how much more effective with this
event it feels just silent if these
things are moving these black shadows
and they're just watching or may just
that low base that they had in the other
films I was so ingenious you know where
it's like not a sound it's just this
basis sort of not even a humming it just
this treble and like it was so effective
in the first two films and say it's all
you need to do and they they don't do it
they have the dumb sound effects that I
guess the camera picks it up picks up
the sound somehow um even though the
girl is clearly talking to this thing
and it's talking back but it doesn't
pick that up and again it's I guess
nitpicking but um so at the one thing
about the scares I'll say is I like the
idea of the camera that can see the goes
and talking to the videocassettes and
for lack of better way of putting this
that it had good jump scares and jump
scares are lame and we hate them in
stuff but this one had kind of good
build up to him you didn't know when
they were coming and they got a good
jump and they were not like oh it was
just my wife playing a joke
terho you know it was legitimately a
ghost flies by or you know look at you
or something like that but after it's
done it's not like oh that's stuck with
you that was really scary you know it's
a boo but they're well timed they're
well time boos it's kind of like going
through a haunted house and it's like oh
where are they gonna jump out oh there
he was but that person jumped out isn't
gonna stay in your nightmares or
anything where you know some of the
other films like those images will uh so
but before I get to the actual ending of
this the one really good thing like
chillingly good thing in this movie is
that they have this little girl in the
movie and the acting is passable from
most of the peopie me it's by once in a
while you'll get like a really roll your
eyes thing and it's not well written
film this is bad dialogue and everything
but once in a while you'll get some
people like you know they're doing their
best you can tell and and they're
they're passable at saying these
terrible lines but the little girl in
this movie is really fuckin phenomenal
uh I don't think I'm giving anything
away by saying she's becoming possessed
or something stalking to her that's
every goddamn movie uh so you but she
starts off as a real kid I mean she
looks sounds feels everything is like a
real kid and you know runs around and
talks like a real kid would uh and then
she's getting more and more possessed
like this kid there's a wonderful scene
where this priest comes in and he's like
you know hi can you know you know you
got a little something on your head
there and he pour some holy water eyes
him puts a little cross on her head and
stuff like that and it's legitimately
kind of cool uncomfortable scene and
then like she's already kind of acting a
little weird so you don't know what's
gonna happen and she just sort of look
at them and gives them like this smile
and it's like the creepiest mile it's by
far the scary scene in the movie it's
just a smile and a smile that you can't
pick up yet cuz she hasn't really like
she hasn't you know attacked anyone or
swearing anybody or anything like that
she's just acting a little odd and
started talking to these ghosts and she
just gives this phenomenal face I mean
that is just the scariest thing in the
movie uh and you don't know if it's a
smile of everything's okay or I'm about
to fuck you up and it's just so chilling
and I really want to give it credit
child actress because she's really
fucking good in this and uh yeah I'm
just hoping the fact that this movie you
know never picked up and nobody saw it
and stuff like that I hope she gets work
but but not to a point where in like
Hollywood destroys all the child actors
or anything like that I hope it's like
whatever bounce down stuff but um but
yeah she was exceptionally good in this
even when she has to say really dumb
lines or if she makes them sound very
natural so it's just really great job uh
so are the questions answered like half
of them I mean okay technically what is
it what's going on that is answered why
is still up in the air this has like
fucking time-traveling in it and going
to quote unquote other dimensions but
you don't really see this kind of other
dimension just so it looks like either a
place in the past or something like that
I'm not giving that way that that's in
the trailer um but you figure out what
they're doing but again like the means
and why and how are still not explained
there's like a ton of things that the
other Paranormal Activity movies you buy
well wait well why did they do that or
how did this connect to this or where
did this tie-in with it but you know
basically what's going on and it's
pretty dull it's pretty boring um it's
about unimaginative as you can get but
uh the the last third of this movie
actually goes so batshit crazy and a lot
of people are like well they're
Paranormal Activity movies near the end
I got pretty crazy no this goes this is
ghostbusters it turns into ghostbusters
it is the silliest fucking thing you've
ever seen in your life and it's almost
worth recommending just to see how
fucking ridiculous it gets it is so
silly so fake the effects are beyond
ridiculous and it really is like you're
watching you know a video game like if
this monster coming at you I give way to
get one of those little guns at the
arcade ago it is so stupid it's
amazingly stupid um so all right so with
that's it that's basically the review um
I'll just this goes into spoiler
territory so you get
no idea what I thought I didn't think I
was very good I thought the little girl
in it was very good it's probably a
little better than the last one cuz at
least their stuff I remember in it and
there's one or two ideas or scares or
something I'm like okay this is kind of
a cool concept even it's not done right
and sometimes if jump scares were
effective so it's like you know I'll
give it that that is probably a little
better than the last one uh but yeah it
goes totally becchi insane and this is
where I'm gonna ruin the ending if you
don't want to know about it so this
black thing you know this black ghost
that opens up these dimensions and it's
like it's all the cliched stuff the
bright light opens up the door and the
person you know walks through it and
stuff like that again like ghostbusters
and then they're doing like an exorcism
at the end of this you know or
quote-unquote they're trying to get rid
of the demon than the house and this
thing like the the demon whatever
becomes physical and what it is they
reveal is that I forget if it's they're
trying to create a human form for either
the devil or the Antichrist or like the
servant of the devil something like that
something bad from Hell and you see this
damn thing and it is like just the way
it looks like a doom monster it just
looks like a human that's trying to look
like a doo monster but it's all CG
completely cartoon and literally this
thing comes out starts grabbing people
just rather that's you know whatever
white eyes and super fake CG face and
they throw a blanket on it which is
great you know like that's gonna stop it
you know cuz I can't see it so they try
putting it on and then like fucking
smoke like a tornado is going on in
there and then the black stuff like goes
outside the circle and starts chasing
them around it like this black smoke
monster like the thing from lost like
it's creating this hand it goes through
a guy's chasm because it's 3d it's
writing Aurora trying to get the camera
and it is just so silly and finally like
she travels whatever back in time which
they never explain why they have to go
back in time for this um but
so finally the mother goes in like you
know they finally bring human form to
this evil entity and all you see is like
his feet which just looked like human
feet and he does what everybody does to
the people in these movies the last
final Shou whatever just saw rotates the
mother breaks the neck and the feet walk
off that's it that's the big closer to
paranormal activity I guess it's like
the omen all of them Devils walking
among us now we never see what the
fucking looks like really you see what
the cool look what spirit looks like um
and it's just so dull and so boring
except for when they're being chased
around everything else is on autopilot
but that ending is so amazingly dumb
it's kind of worth checking out just for
that um so yeah it's it's a shame this
series that like you know just thrived
on that minimalism and the subtle
touches and did you see that every
single time I watched the second one I
always notice something I didn't notice
before and in this one it likes it's
ghostbusters you're watching
Ghostbusters 3 if Ghostbusters was a
found footage movie that's what this
would be except it's trying to not be
funny it's trying to be legitimately
scary but it's not it's hilarious so
yeah it's you know I'm glad it's the
final one I kind of said like when this
movie was coming out okay I'm I'm gonna
fall for the gimmick of all the answers
are gonna be here cuz I was curious even
by the end of four you know that big you
know giant army of women out there I'm
just like what is going on I'm
legitimately interested even though I
knew what was getting dumber and dumber
and fifth one didn't answer anything and
so I went to find out I got my answer
it's dumb um and I think the only other
thing that really kind of like bothered
me in terms of like I actually would
like to have seen that was that they
show kind of I guess the demon or the
entity whatever that's talking to the
girl they show a picture she draws a
picture of this thing account looks like
a goat with a bunch of eyes you know
drawn and cran and then they show a
picture like drawn in a book or
something and this
this thing looks fucking creepy in the
book I mean it's like this beautiful
black and white drawing line drawing of
just this yak and like this goat with
all these eyes and it's like oh my god
it's the first time I I was kind of like
I hope I don't see that like I
legitimately don't want to see that in
this film because I think would be too
scary and they don't show it I mean it's
the one time I wanted to see this damn
monster I want to see the damn thing in
all these movies and they don't go
through with it
so it's like why even show it at all if
you're not gonna actually put that on
screen uh you know even though it's just
like a fad a quick flash or something
like that just no none of that so I
don't know it's uh so yeah it's as you
can guess I didn't think it was very
good but I've always talked about the
Paranormal Activity movies so here it is
they did just kind of get dumber and
dumber I take it right from to on they
got dumber and dumber but each one up
until five had something you know
something of interest um and I think the
only thing that really stands out about
this one is the girl the kid in it is
very very good legitimately scary but
again you've seen a lot scary kids in
other films so you could just you know
watch that so um yeah that's about it
that's my thoughts on the final
paranormal activity if they do make
another one I have no interest in seeing
it hopefully this is the last long
because it really seems like it's run
out of steam so but I still love the
second one I love several elements from
the films I'm glad they were made I'm
glad they made a lot of them I kind of
liked that tradition of returning back
to them every Halloween so um yeah there
it is I still think there's so many good
things in the series I think they're
worth watching probably up till four
with the understanding that they will
get dumber and dumber but they're still
still good scares and still such
creativity to the scares and the
building up the suspense and everything
so uh I still think they're worth
watching even though they get lamer and
lamer so that's about it I will talk to
you later bye